a Tennessee judge is offering inmates
less jail time if they get a vasectomy
or a birth control implant Judge Sam
benningfield says his goal is to prevent
babies from being born addicted to drugs
Tennessee has seen a tenfold rise in the
number of babies born with symptoms of
withdrawal since the early 2000s
it's called neonatal abstinence syndrome
or na s and it's yet another effect of
the growing boy opioid epidemic
David big no is in Sparta Tennessee with
how this judge is defending his
controversial action David good morning
good morning the judge here in White
County says he's trying to stop
prospective mothers and fathers from
passing that drug addiction on to their
children and in doing so he says he's
making what is a heartfelt incentive
with nothing but good intentions however
the judges critics say he may be
crossing the line I'm not on a crusade
of any sort I'm trying to help trying to
help people Judge Sam benningfield
estimates that eighty to ninety percent
of the cases that come before him are
tied in some way to drugs or alcohol so
when the local health department
proposed a class for inmates at the
county jail on the risks of harming
their children it seemed to me almost a
no-brainer you know give off of these
women a chance to think about what
they're doing and to try to rehabilitate
their life he issued this twofold
standing order inmates could get two
days knocked off their sentence if they
completed the Department of Health's
Naas educational program on top of that
he offered an additional 30 days off of
an inmate sentence if they undergo a
birth control procedure vasectomy for
men and a contraceptive implant for
women based on your legal expertise do
you think this is illegal I think it is
potentially unlawful yes Bryant Dunaway
is the local district attorney general
his prosecutors handle cases in front of
Judge bidding field it's not the place
of the government or the courts or the
state of Tennessee to encourage the
trading of fertility procedures for
reduction incentives let me push back on
that the judge would say I'm not
encouraging anything I'm simply saying
if you do it you'll get this and so
I disagree with that I think by offering
that as an option on his own he's
encouraging that so far 24 women have
had the implant procedure and 38 men
have signed up for the vasectomy this is
that forced honor judge benningfield
says he was blindsided by the criticism
trying to help these folks you know
begin to think about taking
responsibility for their life and doing
right and giving them a leg up you know
when they get out of jail - perhaps
rehabilitate themselves and not be
burdened again with unwanted children
and it all that comes with them for what
it's worth the County Sheriff fully
supports the judge the ACLU believes the
judge's order is unconstitutional this
free program for inmates is not
sterilization that implant for women at
last three years and men can have their
vasectomies reversed in fact Jeff the
judge told us if a higher court comes in
and tells him he's wrong he is prepared
to reverse his order David Beck no thank
you very much